how do you say what I think I'm wrong it
seems like people like you would be
saying what I'm going to build because I
don't want to count my [ __ ] chickens
shot like honestly like I've done well
I've made it I'm good I want to keep
winning but I don't know like maybe
maybe I fall off like I want to stay
hungry I'm not ready to you know do
rocks like hey this cabbie he knew you
were I'm like Nana he just saw that you
were with you know with a camera with me
like I am big enough ego in me already
I gotta make sure that I've big enough
humility to go with it cuz that's how
you get somewhere second you think
you've won
somebody's gonna crease it's it's so
real that you know a lot of these
cliches and staring at their real yeah
when you're thinking like we see it
every day did you see how I'm going a
little old school but like did anybody
see Buster Douglas walk into that ring
goods Evander Holyfield 31 cuz he's
[ __ ] 40 pounds overweight yeah he
looked like he ate the old buses like
you know like so I'm scared of that like
and especially as for as much [ __ ] as I
talk like I'm gonna buy the Jets like
I'm [ __ ] suffocating myself put myself
in a corner of never being able to let
off